you
25 years ago something called the
Northwest forest plan was put in place
it protected more than 24 million acres
of forest in Northern California Oregon
and Washington on the anniversary of
that law the debate over what to do with
America's ancient forests has come under
new scrutiny who should be in charge of
the future industry or environmentalists
we travel deep into the forest and above
it looking for answers as part of our
continuing series eye on earth November
2 one compute Sierra Bromley to take on
our trip began in a small plane maybe
the best way to see what's happening in
western Oregon our guide Chandra legue
of the group Oregon wild
the views from overhead can be jarring
mountains teeming with towering trees
followed by winding cutouts of nothing
but stumps this is what modern-day
clear-cutting looks like giant machines
handle massive trees like matchsticks
this land has never been lost this is a
place where none of that has happened a
so-called old-growth forest we only have
about 15% of the forests that once screw
trees like this that are left areas like
this were protected by the Northwest
Forest Plan which was signed in 1994 and
impacted more than 24 million acres of
federal land in Oregon California and
Washington was the Northwest Forest Plan
a successor failure from an
environmental perspective it's a success
but we're only 25 years in it's kind of
a long term experiment logging on
federal lands is dropped by as much as
90% but on state-owned and private land
time-lapse of satellite images over
Northwest Oregon give a sense of just
how common clear-cutting still is legue
says it has a lasting impact forests
capture carbon helping to cool the earth
and slow climate change logging
companies are required by law to replant
new trees after clear cuts but it can
take a decade or more before a young
forest absorbs as much carbon as an old
one not every company like yours is
willing to talk about their story or
take us to places like this why why do
you do that I think we as an industry
have not done a very good job
historically of telling our story
Todd Payne is the CEO of Seneca Jones a
timber giant in western Oregon has the
Northwest Forest plan been a success or
failure in your estimation honestly
speaking I think it was a failure Payne
believes the Northwest Forest Plan is
choking growth and the hands-off
approach environmentalists advocate is
leading to more wildfires because
forests have been neglected he took us
to one of Senecas expansive tree farms
an hour
half outside Eugene where they operate
on 50 year cycles this area next to us
was clear-cut about 55 years ago for the
first time and then clear-cut again
three or four years ago three years ago
correct why clear-cut or mimicking what
Mother Nature's done for for billions of
years but this looks traumatic for a lot
of people when they see something like
this I actually look at it quite
different I think it's somewhat
aesthetically pleasing you think that
looks aesthetically pleasing I do maybe
it's a somewhat biased but I look at
this and I see sustainability
rejuvenation timber companies have also
traditionally used a practice called
aerial spraying chemicals drop via
helicopter to kill any vegetation other
than trees used for lumber a lot of
people are concerned about the spring
well I think people are just not
informed well on that subject we use it
once or twice in a 50 year cycle it
ultimately flows somewhere though no it
doesn't a lot of times this stuff
doesn't flow off the landscape the
product will adhere to the vegetation
that it's targeted for and stay there
Nancy Webster who lives up the coast in
Rockaway Beach Oregon is worried those
chemicals seep into her drinking water
the fight between environmentalists and
logging companies is not new but this
seems like the newest chapter right this
affects the fish the wildlife and we are
up against large corporations and to
even counter it you know you need
science and legal help and it's it's
really difficult for small communities
today the situation may be reaching a
critical point because the federal
government wants to suspend a public
review process which logging companies
say needlessly ties them up in court
should there be a public review process
when logging takes place on public lands
well we have professionals in place in
our federal agencies that are managing
these lands and I think we need to let
them do that work in other words he
wants groups like Oregon wild to stay
away the argument is from them that if
they're not able to log people can't
build homes yeah well no one's talking
about shutting down logging we're
talking about what I feel are common
sense chain
is that do less damage to the
environment that we all share Luke you
wants to see forests thin not clear-cut
a far less invasive approach though she
acknowledges it is more expensive and
would produce less lumber I think people
do need to come to grips with the fact
that the wood that they use to build
houses or anything else comes from
clear-cutting
forests in places like Oregon so what
you're saying is there's a price to pay
for a better world I think in order to
make amends in some way that there's a
price to pay for that and I think it's
worth it the global demand for wood over
the next 10 years is expected to
increase 33% so the question is where
that lumber comes from or if it comes
from somewhere the timber industry would
argue that whatever impact their
practices may have it's less than what
it is to use concrete or steel and the
imprint that has globally I would
imagine glass right as in our
skyscrapers here in New York City well
and it's amazing when you look at its
compromise somewhere you got a you got
to find a middle ground on both sides